how's it go red - bareback welcome to
another episode of Hunger Games survival
of the famous okay
beware of the bear trap I just currently
being chased by somebody at the mining
oh yeah I see Nana's yes any nanners ah
the CEO I'd hurts
ah whoa you're totally rip dude you've
got a katana on your back whoa whoa I
have a shield
[ __ ] you what you gonna do huh what you
gonna do against his shield [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah I wish I had I know he's
chasing me
it's chasing back don't don't
he's hitting my shield help me please
someone help me he can't knit you jumped
oh dear ah okay okay guys guys help
where's East East where far is please
for the love of God help me I know we're
good
[ __ ] why through [ __ ] that ah no he's
just run away okay
um okay okay okay okay I'll be Center
soon that's a little South Center please
for the he's right behind me and he's
really scary
oh I'm by the road I'm uh ah yeah oh my
god this person's got everything he's
gonna now makes you skirt - I'm gonna
head to the town I think we should all
head to the town if you know what I mean
oh I don't I don't relax I don't know
what you mean
um a little town I see a little town
over here yes so to identify each other
properly so nothing no accident happens
sing beyond says your favorite Beyonce
song
and beautifully nothing okay I meant
people but if you like it then you
shoulda put a ring on it
oh thank you oh okay here thanks oh this
means if you like it then you share the
butter hi hi
there's a guy there's a leak it's a guy
killeth oh it's Adam no it's me don't
kill me
but that guy that guy hey get that guy
get this guy
who's this he's not singing Beyonce
he's not singing Beyonce proper oh let
me get his gun hassan ii think it's up
yeah listen listen we're gonna barricade
ourselves clear ourselves oh really
herbal would they stop it or I'll kill
you all we're having a steak for dinner
guys oh okay so I'm gonna put a beer
Trappe right okay I'll cut it up for us
if you come it go into this building
there's the best weapon in the game in
this building right here you're taking
who how dare you
I trusted you what happened he made a
bad rap I can't move it it hurts
ahhh oh yay no yes I'm stuck do
something about it Louie okay don't hit
me over trust
I'll good try to get you out o best
weapon in the game huh
best weapon in the game I see how it
can't free so come here come here and
free me come here and free me come here
and free me kayak cool be cool be cool
I'm cool I'm cool all right I can't do
anything I think you're stuck for life
okay you attention server
I know down so you should kill in the
town so if you look on your map okay
he's out that's actually [ __ ] get Tom
gets wrong with you
how is wrong okay I hate y'all
hmm how could you Felix listen alright
let's let's gamble a little bit let's
get this off our chest okay let's
expensive cat okay
sorry for putting a bear trap and you
know just just hurting you with general
not only did you hurt my character but
you hurt my feelings
and your eyeballs your eyeballs are so
derpy right hey okay just again we need
to not kill each other this time okay
I'm sorry
perhaps then I avenge seeing on his
death I was being a good guy you think
about it you're a horrible guy what I
saw you kill him at a bike him yeah I
was making sure that he would not come
back up again
hurry I'm gonna go for the bear trap
straight away so oh yeah I know where it
is you know you be a little sneaky
little I just don't like you I know who
are you makes it's me okay where do I
find a weapon do you have a weapon minx
no I don't have anything and I'm a bit
worried about this yeah me too okay so
you're in the bunker I reckon and have a
look around
I can't following you oh that's out of
this okay that's good that you haven't
in something just don't kill me please
yeah okay oh are you guys doing regular
table okay wait wait wait where are you
guys we're at the time I come into the
town with the bear traps
okay let's cap them how do I [ __ ]
love you after that I'm so sorry
what happened it just looks oh there's a
crossbow from the arrows we were like a
team yeah whoa I have arrows okay all
right no yes yeah I know how to use it
yeah we got lights well there's people
up there no no just me nothing - dude
like Splinter Cell what are they doing
yeah that's a masher I think that's you
guys
then the Splinter selling darkness you
can't see us yeah this enough I'll
finish mounting
I'm trying to shoot them and they're
charging us oh shut up what about us
status how did you get a bow take it
from him take it from no no no no come
up here oh I don't make away cool I'm
trying but it's scary in a friendship
I'm sorry Tom I'm betraying wait wait
wait amazing breezy breezy I think he's
down there okay okay show me your face
so I don't have a face I am the Miss why
are ya crazy lazy he's underneath you
directly uh shoot him oh I can't run I
kill matters oh there's yeah you're an
MLG penis Pro man that was impressive
alright brothers I hope you enjoyed this
episode you can literally see my soul
slowly getting crushed in this episode
once again betrayed by Adam then Tom
then makes oh no I doubt that if you
ever love me leave a like anyway it's
this guy girl birthday I'll see you next
time severed head I swear to God on my
bed
whoa do it and watch it up man get off
me
ugly it's [ __ ] hole